the man circled in red is about to be
killed is February 2017 and Kim jong-nam
the half-brother of North Korean leader
Kim jong-un is at Kuala Lumpur
International Airport suddenly CCTV
shows a woman in white approaching him
deadly VX nerve agent is being smeared
on his face in less than an hour Kim
jong-nam is dead
accused of murder Duan T Hong today
pleaded guilty to causing harm instead a
woman who had been facing a possible
death sentence will now be freed next
month not as far as the one is concerned
we are happy because ultimately she can
go home within a month and AG has
reconsidered our representation prepared
to offer in order to charge and we are
happy with that it's alleged Kim
jong-nam was killed in an audacious
political assassination after falling
out of favour with Pyongyang for North
Koreans wanted over the murder are still
on the run the only other suspect city
aisha was freed last month but Duan
denies being part of a hit squad always
saying she believed it was a harmless TV
prank CCTV shows her grabbing a man's
face at Hanoi Airport less than two
weeks before
vs. is nothing T in this case she
doesn't know anything about this you can
ask the other people I cannot say
anything here Thank You North Korea
strenuously denies any involvement in
the murder but Kim jong-un has executed
potential rivals in the past and six
months before he died his estranged
half-brother told friends his life was
in danger
Kim Jong Un's actions suggest he was
afraid on his final visit here to
Malaysia he traveled using fake
documents to conceal his identity and
the court heard he was carrying vials of
a possible antidote to the X on the day
he died Alex Wang was one of Kim Jong
noms friends he told me for years he'd
feared he would be targeted Kim jong-nam
worries the number one thing is the
kidnapped
number two is killing know anytime
anybody can kill him who do you think it
is then responsible for killing Kim
jong-nam just funny North Korea in a
crowded Airport using one of the most
dangerous chemical weapons on earth Kim
jong-nam was murdered but the real
architects behind this ruthless plot may
never be brought to justice
siobhan Robin's Sky News Kuala Lumpur
Malaysia